thank you so actually the the transition
from dance thing to - smart contracts
consensus so just to say a couple of
things that connect the talks so I want
to just tell you a little bit about
where this is coming from because I
wasn't doing anything with potential
networks or anything like that it
happens it really something and there's
very interesting with financial networks
the talks going to be about what ways
our time is time important in financial
networks and in keeping with this theme
of the larger program real time decision
making real time action and working on
something called self programming
networks and that ended up taking us
towards very accurate clock
synchronization algorithm system and
that has since been tested in some of
these financial networks and elsewhere
and so I'm going to say that there are
some interesting outcomes when this and
that Matt and that's what I'm going to
my talks about okay
there are several people at Stanford who
are involved in the cell programming
networks research one of them is my
colleague Ron Mendel Rosenbloom
operating systems virtual machines
mr.william where co-founder vmware and a
whole bunch of students and who are here
some of them are here dan jank is also
here senior research scientist so why
don't I say something about the
financial networks first and I'm going
to use the slides or some portion of the
presentation that Tom Faye from Nasdaq
allowed me to present so we had a
workshop in Stanford in November and
speaker tom phase I try to get him to
come to this event but he's otherwise
busy couldn't even do a remote
presentation so I'm going to just
few of his slides there's a much larger
presentation you made I'm just gonna use
four slides so there FinTech the tech
part there is a lot of need for tech to
be embraced as viewed not just by the
exchange guys like Nasdaq but also by
those the trade on the exchanges like
the investment banks the hedge funds and
also the payments in retail folks like
you know Reiser MasterCard PayPal retail
bank like Wells Fargo etc so the the
what some of these are what folks are
seeing are there's several things that
they're looking at notice blockchain but
before the Dom fate chose to speak about
our hardware acceleration blockchain
machine intelligent cloud services I'm
actually gonna even tell you about
because the clocks are relevant here and
here and I'm gonna show you how so
when you go to an exchange to like a
Nasdaq or New York Stock Exchange and
you know electronically trading there's
this place called a matching engine and
there are these things called gateways
so all transactions whether of the cell
or by type enter through gateways and
there are a few tens of some sometimes
low hundreds of these gateways and all
the bids make their way the central
matching engine and these networks are
very carefully designed to be almost
precisely the same time from each
gateway to the matching engine a figure
on this later coming later on okay any
mismatch in the time it takes to go from
gateway I to matching engine versus j2
matching engine is equalized almost
immediately by running some slightly
longer wires for example okay there's
also non determinism that can cause
fluctuations in the time it takes and so
the big no-no is a transaction comes at
some gateway I and another transaction
comes
afterwards the gate gateway J as viewed
by some other third party observer but
the second guy gets processed first okay
this is simply the thing that's not
allowed
and all exchanges find really hard to
ensure this doesn't happen so hardware
acceleration is taking the software
components of the trip from the Gateway
entry point to the matching engine
hardware izing them Hardware lends
determinism on the one hand certainly
accelerate has faster processing
capacity but the most important thing it
does is actually hardware pipelines are
fairly deterministic you know takes
exactly the same number of clock ticks
to do something and the certain slight
congestion dependence but modular dot
says when the volume of trading is high
then there's a non determined with a
congestion but otherwise there's no
congestion itself so this was in white
and I just highlighted this this is
Nasdaq and they were also citing the
experience of those who are not trading
we're actually running the end of their
risk process so this is all these
high-frequency trading algorithms rather
algorithms whose parameters are tuned
based on market data so you you see what
happened today you go tune your
parameters come back tomorrow and then
you know do it again repeat and that
used to take a long time now it takes
you know it took eight hours is taking
only 238 seconds or so okay so this is
one way in which time is critical not
they're trying to remove the non
deterministic components okay so I'm
going to jump through several of his
slides to cloud so this is all fine when
you have designed your exchange and it
sits in some data center that you
completely manage and you've equalized
this sort of time from gate with a
matching engine but that's not giving
you the sort of scale that you want not
like coinbase in the cloud mean there's
this whole retail exchange it retail
traders on exchange that's become very
interesting so what if we move this from
this data center that I've handcrafted
to something in the cloud and there's no
such guarantees available on you know
time from gateway to matching engine
okay so this is a part of a longer thing
I will click through to this few few key
points I'm gonna get to these in the
second half of my talk fair access this
is the point about this regulator
regulatory requirements that the time
taken fair acts is exactly what I said
too earlier before to you before
transaction shall be processed in the
order in which they arrived no matter
what gateway they arrived at that's
critical and cloud environments don't
have high-precision synchronized clocks
because if they were there then that's
one way in which you could restore
reorder transactions before you execute
the matching engine so that's where this
is very helpful okay so what are we
talking about in terms of time and so
these are from some some Nasdaq's
perspective but there's also other
reasons in four other players why time
is critical I will get to that later
I just want to motivate that there is a
world in which both real-time decision
making an action are very important and
erase the fractional industry so what is
self programming that were just a few
slides so not just sort of leaving you
with no idea what what we're doing and
why accurate clocks ended up being
important for us so self programming
networks is a quest to make networks
being is autonomous and interactive so
it like networks go to a cloud
environment like Amazon or Google or
Microsoft or your own private data
center and we'd like to get this network
the sensor monitor itself and allocates
its resources that's what I mean by
program and controllers there's lots and
lots of little decisions made bandwidth
allocation CP allocations memory
allocations all these allocations which
want to automate them okay there's a
sort of a dashboard that is designed to
have queries and stuff the answer and
this is both something we've taken on
board as something we will do and you
can there's a sort of natural language
to SQL sort of translator
which is there's a chat board that
allows us to do this and so that that's
a whole bunch of walk and done by a
bunch of students here so they gain also
getting a little bit more crisp at least
you know in terms of definition let's
call this a plain old data center there
are a whole bunch of servers and they
interconnected through a fabric of
switches and links is where every day
they send it all day looks like he's
processing some workload I support some
apps okay a self-programming network is
just a shim where you go to this plain
old data center and you send something I
will tell you what and then you process
it and then you exert real-time control
where the control can come from
bottlenecks in the network and or just
operator policies things like the app
can't have more than this amount of
bandwidth it's actually that's that's an
operative policy and there's something
that you can use to peer into this data
center now the nice thing about this is
if we could do it we will get some new
functionality that wasn't available in
this plain old data center for example
very accurate time stamping in the
service final a network telemetry etc
and then that allows you to run some new
apps that it could not run in this plain
old data center okay so I will tell you
what they are and you know as we go
so just to be because it's trying to
link in the previous session okay so
this is like a plain old Volkswagen
Touareg you have some sense in control
to it and becomes a sub driving car
sebastian strong okay so this
transformation costs it about thirty
percent of the cost of this car so it
takes twenty thousand dollars additional
to go from there to here so be nice if
the data centers could be self
programming at three to five percent of
the cost that's it that's an
aspirational goal let's say so now what
is this precisely all our sensing and
control we're going to take make it of
the network interface cards so the
switches are when we're not relying on
the switches okay so this is one key
point
so our lidar and our steering and gas
everything is all on the Knicks network
interface cards so historically if you
go to a data center there's only two
boxes that matter servers and switches
and the Knicks are like doormats
packages wipe their feet when they go
into the server or wipe their feet and
they go out that's about it okay so now
people are building smart necks and this
is a very interesting proposition so
this is what our work is and this is the
subject of my talk next week so I'm
going to skip through to the what's the
outcome here so when we say we're
sensing everything from the neck we're
going to do it like this
in this data center for every packet
that enters the data center we're going
to take that transmit timestamp at the
origin Nick and the receive timestamp
for the destination Nick and just
knowing this total time spent by the
packet
we're algorithm weekly like to decompose
it into the time spent in each box this
is known as the tomography problem
already in the literature was attempted
heavy in the internet world where it
wasn't very successful there were a lot
of good results but it wasn't like
jumping out into the real world but the
data center the setting is about right
most things because around you know the
wire time is significantly small
compared to the Box time that's what
makes it work out ok so there's various
reasons why it's interesting but I'm
gonna just tell you that many people are
building smart Nick's
almost all the big hyper scale guys are
doing it lots of Intel Mellanox Broadcom
a whole bunch of guys building Nixa
building smart Nick's there's also bunch
of startup so this is sort of an
appropriate meeting but the moment you
see this picture I'm taking a timestamp
here and a time stand there if the
clocks are not synchronized this is
useless
ok so two summers ago
Elan gang who's here had access to
Google 40g data center and we had
already done this
the reconstruction algorithm at Stanford
sort of simulated widely is network
simulator then we went to he went to
Google and the clocks are completely out
of sync
ok like off by a few tens of
microseconds
you know or bigger or maybe a couple
hundred sometimes and that just doesn't
work for anything we want okay so we
don't know how to synchronize the clocks
there's a system that this led us to
doing that I'm going to skip through the
next few slides just for in the interest
of time so I would summarize the
algorithms the output is the summary
point is that it can synchronize to a
few large number of servers to a few
nanoseconds okay and so this is better
than anything you can do even with
special hand-built hard way okay so the
system itself is like you know just to
conclude this right you start with the
plain old data center you issue a set of
probes and you take data packet just
take the x time sort us in some database
this is sort of big query for us in the
cloud and then you push it through this
pipeline our first synchronize in the
clocks then the reconstruction algorithm
and you've got your sensing part at
least done now the quest is to make it
real time and then at scale and then
apply control okay all right so once
learn what is the scope synchronization
solution I'm not I don't have time to
tell you more about it because I want to
tell you about what it means with
finance so we call it Huygens for a
particular reason
and it synchronizes clocks to ten two
nanoseconds or even single-digit
nanoseconds depending on the network
it's been tested at various data centers
and some of these guys are financial
data centers like Nasdaq is tested it so
there it's all typically single-digit
nanoseconds because the load isn't so
high has compared these other big data
centers and otherwise in the few tens of
nanoseconds and if you know what this
means it might mean something to you
Network Time Protocol very widely used
for since that Lee 70s it's purely
software it's off by a few hundred
microseconds to a few milliseconds this
is a similar in complexity for
deployment but just faster and so since
the financial industry needs very
accurate clock synchronization they use
precision time protocol and pulse per
second is based on GPS and they need
specialized hardware okay so that's it
so that's it I'm not going to say any
more about clocks ink
but that it is necessary for us to do
something else and it happens to have
this interesting use cases so how does
it work in few slides to compute just a
title okay what is finance industry care
about clocks for first of all there are
business requirements okay and they are
this fairness the correct sequencing of
orders according to arrival times before
execution the matching engine every
exchange measures this very carefully
very carefully the measure if this is
happening or not and but you know
there's not easy ways of remedying this
currently smart contracts this is an
interesting topic in and of itself by
the way one version of it that relies on
clocks is you want to simultaneously
release this market data and other
information so in the Nasdaq slides the
one that I'd FPGA it sort of talked
about how they're speeding up things but
as well you know releasing things
simultaneously so nobody gets any
advantage day if possible but another
more enhanced interesting version of
smart contract could be I make you an
offer to sell some number of shares or
foreign exchange our trade with you that
is only valid between microsecond x and
X plus y otherwise the price will change
okay and really the only thing that can
react to that speed is more or less
hardware but you need a clock to just be
smilin you're super synchronized or
yours and all the other people all for
this trick should be synchronized okay
that's an example of what's coming
transaction tracking is very you know
whether an exchange or in the sort of
payments industry this is sort of a big
deal everybody wants to really
understand this reconstruction part so
there's something called market playback
this is one I said so you go do
everybody does this sort of risk there's
all the simulations that they do so
almost all our sort of grad students are
getting hired from the MLA high classes
in the financial industry are all
sitting and sort of figuring out their
they're running this market playback
okay so the this requires you to have
the ability to playback the different
feeds that came to you
and pretty much the exact time sequence
that are arrived at you okay that's what
that is so there's a lot of dispute
settling and then there's compliance
requirements but I really something goes
bad they have to have traceability okay
so the European Union notably has put
this thing of a transaction separated in
fact by one microsecond in actual time
shall be so timestamp this is a
requirement that's gone into effect
January this year and this is driving a
lot of the industry to move since
accurate clocks okay so a promise how
does this picture on matching engine
services from the euro next six to zero
next exchange so here are all the
sessions this could be the broker
traders they're putting out this bids
little a capital A B DC from these guys
and so on and there's some number of
gateways one through n here where the
timestamps are taken it would be great
if the x times the order in which they
arrived here is exactly the order in
which they get executed here but there's
a sequencing point that can in principle
restore the order okay and so this is
really what some of the work we're doing
is already it's very interesting for but
on the output side this is the market
data coming on the order book electronic
order book information 1 2 etcetera
feeds and these are all going back to
these guys aren't others who are you're
gonna use that to come back with another
bit okay that's what it is now the time
stand the transactions here very
accurately and then resequenced am here
before execution that's great no we're
working on conversely if we could also
ensure that nobody receives all the
books ahead of anybody else if possible
then that'll be another thing about fair
fairness and so ok they I want time
clearly the one last slide on they can
enable yeah I've told you something very
specific very particular so it looks
like is all the exchanges in the world
including some new exchange that are
coming up in the cloud so I've been
doing all this in the clouds you know
this this picture is done for data
centers that are people are building
very carefully
but moving this the cloud can be enabled
with this clocks distributed databases
so if you've heard a spanner this global
database from Google's guarantees
external consistency runs on a very
precise set of clocks down to seven
milliseconds synchronized around the
world called true time if you can crank
that down to something much slower then
you read retry probability will go down
and the throughput can increase and
various positive nice things can happen
so this is one place Ledger's everybody
has to see things exactly the same order
and ignoring the congestion is required
to incentivize miners think of think of
the severe ledges that where Trust is
not the issue but it's just used for
maintaining like in foreign exchange
market for example and we spoke about
this there your interests in high
throughput and transactions but you want
an ordering service that gives all that
all the pairwise transactions that are
taking place between nodes are ordered
so that goes in the overall single
ledger a copy of which is available
everywhere in the right sequence so at
any point I know how much balance you
hold worse is you hold a markets where
it's not a listed stock don't have a
central matching engine so transactions
are happening pairwise like foreign
exchange and pub/sub systems if you know
what that is Kafka for example so almost
all the financial industry guys use it
brawls or others and used for many
things of consistency ordering services
leader election everything is some
consensus algorithm and if you're
accurate clocks I can speed this up and
so I've mentioned smart contracts and
peer-to-peer trading so I'll stop there
and thank you
[Applause]
do financial markets worry about Mountie
they do they do well it complicates it
in the sort of a challenging sense like
you know what Dan was saying then it
just what we should be working on it
even more okay but even something that
is known so all all all the books a
single asset so if another word what
that means is if I want to sell Google
shares or Amazon shares and get some
other shares then I have to go through
dollars there under stairs directly of
shares okay but the existence of
multi-asset order books is known there's
since 72 mertens jean-francois modems as
described how they can be built and you
know you can do it that's an example of
something that can be enabled if you
have trading systems that not sort of
the star-shaped go to the single
matching engine and so so it's not it's
not multi-party but multi-asset right
there are multi-party thing where you
know little like I will give you this
drawer you will give that like that does
that exist but I'm not very familiar
maybe see a Mac knows more about such
things but existing exchanges for a
single asset or are the multi-party if
you go in and put it in order to buy a
thousand shares of Google you might be
transacting with ten different people
are there ways to use provable
guarantees
so if you look I'd like you know there's
something that it was very interesting
questions I can for sure say that the
time is after 4:00 p.m. but but before
5:00 p.m. right so the larger the
granularity of time is the more easy
needs to be certain then it's all
probabilistic down in the nanos and
Pecos even in the micro SD already so
from true time onwards is a probability
guarantee you just almost impossible to
be accurate 100% okay so yes that is
simply you test it and you can prove
some things to mathematically
why is this ordering of transactions why
is it such a premium placed on you must
must process changes the value of the
asset so if you want to buy some number
of shares and I'm simply gonna come
after you and dump it dump those shares
then the price you know it's crabby
either be artificially low artificially
high depending on which side you know
the thing is I was selling c-max so this
is almost is getting the final
discussion level but I would just answer
this in elaborated way I was shocked in
following thing I had never heard ever
heard I know layer 2 switching that's
easier next which is layer threes IP
switching I never heard of layer 1
switching but simply is an optical you
know great diffraction greater but
grating then there's a I heard of a
switch from a company called meta amico
and that's what they're doing they're
doing layer 1 switching because they
just can't afford to wait okay so who's
responding and flipping back this thing
at such great speeds FPGAs so the
parameter is also an FPGA is there's
sort of lazier algorithms are maybe
looking at data undoing that ml whatever
they're doing and then they come back
and set parameters and FPGAs
that's what's flipping this and it's
coming back the velocity is very high
there's there's instances of time where
you know let's say you're looking at
equities and the S&P 500 goes up one
tick right well every right so if you
notice that price change